翻訳: Abram Leon
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さん こんにちは
私は「人が育つ 教え方」を研究しています
個人の能力を 最大限に引き出す方法を考えて
その方法を教えるのが 大好きなんです
こんな私を ある人が
「教え方研究家」と呼んでくれました
個人的には その呼び方を
とっても気に入っています
どんな事を教えてきたか と言うと
例えば
初心者を「スカイスポーツ」の大会で
いきなり優勝させたり
企業で 自ら動ける人材を育成したり
最近では 英語の発音矯正を
したりしています
今日は 私がどうやって
「人が育つ 教え方」にたどりついたのか
そのルーツについて
話をしたいと思います
皆さんは ハンググライダーというのを
ご存知ですか？
三角形の翼で
人がぶら下がって空を飛ぶモノです
翼の端から端まで約10メートル
翼の下には 三角形のコントロールバー
というものがあり
それをこう軽く握って
機体をコントロールします
ちなみに これが
ハンググライダーのコントロールバーです
ちょっと持ってみましょうか
実は私は このハンググライダーの
元日本チャンピオンなんです
でも もともと私は運動音痴で 体力も無く
子供の頃から 何一つ
人並みにできた事がありませんでした
そんな私を変えてくれたのが
ハンググライダーだったのです
16歳の時 私は
ハンググライダーを始めました
ハンググライダーの難しいところというのは
例えば ほんの少し右手を握りすぎるだけで
右に飛んで行ってしまうとこです
私も練習を始めたころ
よく練習場の横の草むらに
突っ込んだりしていました
ある時先輩が こう言ったんです
「手を放しても飛ぶんだ 力をいれるな」と
私は思いきって両手を放してみました
そしたら 何と
とても安定して飛んだんです
それをきっかけに 私は
手の力を抜いて空を飛ぶコツをつかみました
私にとって 初めてできたスポーツが
ハンググライダーだったんです
私は 私自身に自信をつけてくれた
このハンググライダーを
究めてみたいと思いました
19歳の時 一人でオーストラリアに渡り
なんと 幸運にも
世界チャンピオンに
弟子入りするのに成功しました
でもそこは 私にとって
「必死に生き残る」っていう言葉が
ぴったりな環境でした
浜辺で
「トーイング」と言うのですが
こう —
「凧揚げ」のように
ハンググライダーをモーターボートで
引っ張って 飛んだ時の話です
浜辺ですから 水着を着て はだしで
ヘルメットも被らず
ハンググライダーを構えます
機体には こんなアルミパイプがついていて
その先に ステンレスの金具があって
そこに ロープを取り付けます
でこうやって 準備ができると
足で合図をするのですね
足で合図をすると 今度はモーターボートが
水しぶきを上げながら 爆走してきます
目の前には そのロープが
Ｓ字を描いて置いてあって
モーターボートが進むにつれて
「シャンシャンシャシャシャシャバン！」
と張って
ロケットのように「ドカーーン！」
と上がっていくんです
その瞬間です —
しかも初めて飛んだ時です
ロープがバンって張った瞬間に
アルミパイプの先の金具が引っ張られて
「ガン！」って当たって
おでこが「カパ」っと開いて
血が「ピュー」っと噴き出したんです！
（笑）
でそのまま 高度100メートルまで
一気に「グワー！」って上がって行きました
ちなみに そのモーターボートを
運転していたのが
世界チャンピオンのお父さんなんです
彼は 飛び出す前
私にこんなアドバイスをしてくれました
「いいか ここは入り江だから
サメはいないけど
たまに迷い込んでくるから
必ず浜辺に降りろよ」と言われたんです
（笑）
私は 血[を]「ピュー」っと出[し]ながら
ロープを切り離し
必死にコントロールして
そして飛びたった場所に
フワリと着陸しました
「フー」って感じですよね はい
日本だったらどうですかね？
もしこう 血がピューって出ながら
降りてきたら
「大丈夫かー？！」って
みんな寄ってきて 大騒ぎになりますね
ところが 私がフワリと着陸すると
すでにモーターボートは
水しぶきを上げながら走っていて
着陸した途端
ロープを「カチャ！」と付けられて
次の瞬間 また「ドカーーン！」
と飛ばされたんです
（笑）
結局そのまま
３回続けて飛ばされました
３回も飛んでいると
血も乾いてきて 止まるんですね
（笑）
しかも ２回目からは
ガンって当たったのが分かってますから
今度は金具を「フッ」っとこう よけて
そういうコツも覚えました
（笑）
着陸するとそのお父さんが
うれしそうな顔で寄ってきて
こう言ったんです
「よくやった！いいか？
腕が折れようが 足が折れようが
コントロールは 絶対に失ってはいけない！」
と言ったんです
ここで重要なことは 最後の最後まで
自分の意志でコントロールし続ける事なんです
もし コントロールを
途中であきらめてしまったら
その時点で 墜落してしまうんです
実は 彼は
ハンググライダーのパイオニアで
文字通り 命がけで
歴史を築いてきた人なんです
彼にとっては
血を流す事は些細な事だったんです
そんな彼に育てられた世界チャンピオンも
サメのいる海で ６歳のころから
飛ばされたそうです
（笑）
私にとっても「必死に生き残る」
という毎日だったんですね
もう一つ 言葉の問題もありました
ハンググライダーのテイクオフというのは
たいてい山の上にあるんですね
そうすると例えば 飛び立つ瞬間に
誰かが私の翼に当たってしっまったら
私はバランスを崩して 墜落してしまいます
なので「すみませーん
私の翼を触らないでくださーい」と
カタカナ英語で
「プリーズドントタッチマイウィング！」と
言っても 残念ながら通じません
100％通じるクリアな発音で
（英語）「おい 俺の翼に触るなよ」
大声で叫ばないといけないんです
私は
「どうしたら相手に英語が通じるのか？」
自分の命を守るために
確実に通用する方法を考えていました
私は 言葉が通じなくても
一応 ハンググライダーという
共通の話題のおかげで 友人ができました
彼は 私の英語があまりにも通じないので
見かねて
自分の子供に教えるように
発音の仕方をゆっくりと見せてくれたんです
見よう見まねで同じ口の形を作ると
何と 同じ音が私の口から出たんです
通じる発音ができるようになると
だんだんと英語が聞き取れるようになってきて
気が付けば 英語で コミュニケーションが
取れるようになっていました
話は少し変わって
私が初めて 国際大会に出た時の話です
ハンググライダーの競技というのは
例えば 100キロのコースを
その日の気象条件に合わせて設定して
上昇気流をつかまえて
１秒でも早くゴールした者が勝ちます
大きな大会になると
100機以上が同時に 飛ぶ事があります
大会初日 初めての国際大会ですね —
大会初日
私は最初の上昇気流が見つからなくて
最下位になってしまいました
ちなみに 皆さん 上昇気流って
何色だと思いますか？
（客席）空色？
（田中）良いとこですね はい
実際はですね 無色透明なんです
（笑）
見えないんですね
で次の日に
私の師匠である世界チャンピオンが
私が０点を取ったんで
見かねて言ったと思うのですが
「今日は 一緒に飛ぼう！」って
言ってくれたんです
で 「お やった！」と思いながらですね
次の日 私がテイクオフしようとすると
彼が 私にこう言ったのです
「いいか？真っ直ぐ飛んでいくと
あの丘の所に
上昇気流があるから」って言うんです
「あれ？上昇気流 見えないよな
本当にあるのかな？」と思って
半信半疑でテイクオフすると
ちょうどその丘の上で 「ドカーン」と
強い上昇気流にヒットしたんです
で「おおー！」と思いながら回り始めたら
なんと 対角線に 師匠がそこに
もう飛んでいたんですよ
私がテイクオフした直後に
彼がテイクオフして
私が回り始めた上昇気流の上に
ぴったりと 乗ってきたんです
で 無線で彼が
「いいか！高度5500メートルまで上昇したら
あの山に向かって行くぞ！ほら行け！」
「もう少し右のコースだ！
そろそろヒットするぞ
ほら ヒットした！」
そんな感じでどんどん飛んで行って
その勢いで
あっという間に
２人で一気にゴールを決めました
なんと その時の私のタイムは
200人ぐらい出ている大会なんですが
トップ10に入るタイムだったのです
私の中で何かが 大きく変わった瞬間でした
一番になる人は 一番になる方法を
知っていたんです
２人して ゴールに着陸すると
彼が 笑顔で私の所にやって来て
こう言ったんです
「どうだ！簡単だっただろ！」
もう とっても簡単でしたよ
だって ただの一度も
ミステークを起こさないで
そのまま 上昇気流を効率よく捕まえて
楽勝でゴールしたんです！
もう とっても簡単でした
やっぱり飛んでて分かったのが
私自身がそういう
世界一の環境で飛んでいたので
気がつけば 21歳の時に
当時競技を始めて３年目に
最年少で
日本チャンピオンになる事ができました
18歳の時に 私は ハンググライダーの
インストラクターになってから
色々な分野で 人を教えてきました
私の教え方の原点というのがありまして
それはスカイスポーツなんです
スカイスポーツと一般的な教育の違いは
何だと思いますか？
スカイスポーツの場合
教えた事を生徒ができなかった場合
最悪の場合 墜落して
死亡事故に至るのです
なので 生徒の命を守る為に
知識として教えるのではなく
技術として 相手に必ずできるように
しなければいけないんです
指導の現場で たまに
「彼にはセンスが無いから 難しいね」って
聞くことがありますよね
本当にそうでしょうか
技術とは 些細なことの積み重ねなんです
で その一つ一つの些細な事というのは
実はとてもシンプルなんです
もし 何かに挑戦し できなかった時
できないのは
センスや能力が無いからではないのです
そのシンプルなやり方が
分からなかっただけなんです
本当の技術とは
知識に裏付けられた経験です
「一番になる人」というのは
その一番になる方法を知っていて
それを実践しているんです
私は30年間 「教え方」を研究してきて
わかった事があります
スポーツでも 勉強でも 仕事でも
成し遂げるために必要な技術というのは
とてもシンプルで
分野が違っても
ほとんど同じだったという事です
専門的な部分があるとしても
実は ほんの少しでした
言い方を変えれば
もし やり方がわかれば
誰でもできる ということなんです
私が 人を「一番」にできる理由 —
これどういうことかというと
実は僕は今まで 色んな選手を育ててきて
結構 大会で優勝させているのですね
最近だと スノーボーダーのアルペンの
競技に出ている子を ちょっと１人教えていて
ついこの間ですね
北米選手権で優勝しました
なんで私が 人を一番にできるかというと
私自身が何一つ
人並みにできなかった[から]です
で こんな自分でも 必ず
できる方法があるはずだっと思って
ずーっとずっと 探してきたんです
そのやり方を人に教える方法が
「教え方」だと思っています
物事を成し遂げるためには
すべてのことを 必死になって
最高水準まで
突き詰めて 準備して
そして本番では
力を抜いて 最高の結果を出す
この一番になるという方法を
これからも本気で 教えていきたい
と思っています
是非 皆さんもこれを機会に
本気でやり方を探して
何か新たな挑戦を始めてほしい
と思います
どうも ご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）